only place in the world that speech is
protected by law yeah you can still get
in trouble by saying [ __ ] you can still
get protestors Oh Michelle wolf Duncan
the president today no no she dunked on
Trump
dude this Donald Trump talk [ __ ] about
her saying that she bombed so hard last
year at the White House press
Correspondents Dinner which
unfortunately for him we've all seen the
video and she didn't bomb yeah at all in
fact she killed she had some funny [ __ ]
and so he wrote today that she bombed so
hard they're now gonna bring someone
like they're not gonna do comedy anymore
they're gonna bring in an author here it
is yes so-called comedian Michelle
warwolf I'm so badly yes here in the
White House Correspondents Dinner that
that this year for the first time in
decades they will have an author instead
of a comedian good first step and a
comeback with dying evening and
tradition exclamation point maybe I will
go question mark
she writes I bet you'd be on my side if
I had killed a journalist hashtag best
will get she's got two hundred and
ninety seven thousand seven hundred
sixty-nine likes sixty-four thousand one
hundred sixty-nine retweets one of which
is mine little that [ __ ] is hilarious
she's she's a savage and he's that's
silly what he did was silly you can't
say someone but but he does I mean
that's his move right just it doesn't
have to be real but you shouldn't say
someone bombed when we could watch the
fact that it didn't bomb yeah you pull
it up at any time you want oh she can
say that though cuz since the the people
that have seen it no she didn't bomb but
the people that didn't see it now they
think she don't think it matters I think
in the mag of mindset okay if you had a
mag of mindset it would be you don't
need any reality other than the reality
they all decide upon and you press
forward with [ __ ] hashtags and
American flags and red and white hats
and you just keep moving you just keep
moving and eventually what you're doing
is you're like hacking the news cycle
cuz the news cycle is just so everything
lasts a day maybe two days four days
sick no he's a [ __ ] about stormy Daniel
stop talking about story it's over like
that's what's going on I mean that's
it's and they've kind of figured that
out in sort of an odd way like even him
with a storm
Danis thing still talked about it it'll
go away it's going away not only that
like the [ __ ] lawyer now he got
charged with domestic violence the
lawyer for stormy day yeah yeah the guy
who was gonna run for president now he
got charged with domestic violence and
check out a restraining order it's over
baby
so hit like you just keep moving all
they do is just keep moving just keep
moving and eventually it could like this
like yeah
obviously she didn't bump he can say she
did and even she dunks in him keep
moving just given it nothing ever sticks
because he's caught a wave like there's
the new cycle so crazy everything so
crazy there's nothing stationary that we
call can examine for long periods of
time everything's just moving
everything's just constantly moving this
there's no stability it's chaos of him
in the White House he knows there's no
stability because he actually got to be
the president yeah he figured [ __ ] like
he treats everyone like a comic treats
hecklers yes and he's and people that
that say that he's stupid he's he's so
smart like he figured yeah he figured
all this [ __ ] figured out that all the
protocol that was established in the
[ __ ] 1800s and early 1900s that
doesn't mean anything anymore you know
this is not Harry Truman yeah this is
this is not George Washington this is
2018 there's porn everywhere
okay oxycontin's are killing people and
no one's talking about it cigarettes are
killing people no politician ever brings
up the fact half a million people die
every year in this country just from
cigarettes shut the [ __ ] up keep moving
and then you know he said he had that
little Jeff Sessions a little munchkin
working for him forever saying that good
people don't smoke marijuana like the
whole thing's chaos he knows it's chaos
because he's the top guy you imagine
being the top guy and something as
insane as like the United States
governmental system and seeing all the
lobbyists and special interest groups
and all the money and all the [ __ ]
cast in Saudi Arabia's cutting up
journalists and you got to keep your
mouth shut it's [ __ ] madness and he's
the top madman